should have got paid up front banner you
know for a man who's supposed to be
avoiding stress he picked hell of a
place to settle avoiding stress isn't
the secret and what is it yoga you
brought me to the edge of the city smart
I assumed the whole place is surrounded
just you and me and your actress buddy
is she a spy too they start that young I
did who are you Natasha Romanoff are you
here to kill me miss Romanoff because
that's not gonna work out for everyone
no no of course not I'm here on behalf
of shield field how they find me we
never lost you doctor we've kept our
distance even helped keep some other
interested parties off your scent why
Nick Fury seems to trust you but now we
need you to come in what if I say no
I'll persuade you and what if the other
guy says no you've been more than a year
without an incident I don't think you
want to break that streak well I don't
every time did what I want doctor we're
facing a potential global catastrophe
hey are those I actively try to avoid
this is the tesseract it has the
potential energy to wipe out the planet
what does fury want me to do swallow it
he wants you to find it it's been taken
it emits a gamma signature that's too
weak for us to trace there's no one that
knows gamma radiation like you do if
there was that's where I'd be
so fury isn't after the monster not that
he's told me when he tells you
everything talk to fury he needs you on
this he needs me in a cage no one's
gonna put your stuff away to me I'm
sorry that was me I just wanted to see
what you do why don't we do this the
easy way where you don't use that and
the other guy doesn't make a mess okay
Natasha
stand down just you and me
you